desde que terminó el verano el rostro de
europa ha mutado de aperturas a esto una
segunda tanda de rebrotes que inquieta
especialmente en estos países en españa'
madrid afronta su segundo estado de
alarma este de 15 días por una gran
incidencia de casos el dilema es que
además de cargar con una comunidad el
cómic 19 se ha convertido en un pulso
entre el gobierno central y la
presidenta madrileña mientras esta
insiste en cerrar solo algunas zonas de
la región el ejecutivo lo considera
insuficiente y ha desplegado a 7.000
agentes para evitar que hayan entradas y
salidas en este puente festivo en medio
los ciudadanos están desconcertados por
las medidas las normas para la comunidad
autónoma de madrid serán las mismas que
estaban en vigor ayer ni una más ni una
menos y tendrán la cobertura del estado
de rana en la vecina francia varias de
las grandes ciudades entrarán este
sábado en el nivel máximo de alerta con
más de 20.000 casos en un día se temen
meses difíciles y así está e italia con
más de 5 mil infecciones como en marzo y
uso obligatorio de mascarilla en
exterior además de alemania que supera
los 4.500 contagios
y su dato diario más alto desde abril
allí la epidemia se está expandiendo al
punto que el gobierno decidió endurecer
las medidas en las ciudades que reporten
más de 50 casos por cada 100.000
habitantes de no tener buenos resultados
en 10 días vendrán más restricciones
además el aumento de infecciones es tan
rápido en algunas ciudades que casi
hemos llegado a este punto si llegamos a
este punto del virus se propagará sin
control algunos de nuestros amigos
europeos lamentablemente lo están
experimentando ahora durante una segunda
ola pandémica
en la enat fighting tándem y vélez en
polonia república checa y rusia el mal
es compartido registrando este viernes
el mayor número de contagios en una
única jornada